Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
« Chut ! », dit-elle.
Ça commence.
Bien avant que je ne vous le dise,
vous aviez entendu
ce que le personnage de Linette -
créé par C. Romat et J.-P. Peyraud
aux éditions de la Gouttière -
vous suggérait de faire.
Et lorsque son compagnon de jeu, ce petit
personnage bleu, élève la voix à son tour,
vous avez aussi vu le mouvement
qu’il accomplit, ce petit bond,
et l’effet produit sur Linette,
entre peur et étonnement.
Avec quelques codes graphiques simples,
une bulle, des traits de mouvement,
des gouttes de sueur autour de la tête,
la bande dessinée a inventé, et invente
encore dans sa production contemporaine,
mille façons de nous donner accès
aux déplacements, [inaudible],
au son, à la voix, aux émotions.
Ces autrices et ces auteurs ont surtout
la capacité à nous raconter des histoires
en posant côte à côte
des traits auxquels ils donnent du sens.
Ces traits s’organisent en dessins,
forment des cases -
on parle aussi de vignettes.
Côte à côte,
ça aura vraiment son importance
lorsqu’il s’agit d’essayer de s’approcher
d’une définition, même simple et rapide,
de la bande dessinée.
En effet, une image unique
peut raconter, certes,
mais le neuvième art,
puisque c’est ainsi qu’on l’appelle,
apparaît et se déploie à partir du moment
où 2, 3, 4, 6, 8, 12 vignettes
sont organisées sur l’espace d’une page
et nous offrent côte à côte
une lecture originale,
à la fois simultanée et séquentielle.
Les voix de la bande dessinée,
je les ai entendues à l’âge de six ans.
Je viens d’un gros bourg, à une centaine
de kilomètres d’ici, au nord-est.
Une famille ouvrière.
Pas beaucoup de livres à la maison,
juste un abonnement au Reader’s Digest.
Oui, je le disais comme ça à l’époque.
Je ne sais pas
qui ici a croisé cette revue, épaisse,
une centaine de pages,
petit format, petit prix,
qui proposait des versions
abrégées et simplifiées
de romans,
de classiques de la littérature,
et d’extraits d’articles de presse
parus aux États-Unis.
Nous venions d’emménager à Amiens
et un jour,
j’ai demandé à ce qu’on m’achète
une revue de bande dessinée
au café du coin.
Il s’agissait de Pif gadget,
qui paraissait toutes les semaines,
accompagné, comme son nom l’indique,
d’un petit objet plus ou moins
insolite, sous plastique.
Mais ce n'était pas le plus important.
Le plus important,
c’est qu’il y avait des BD.
Des bandes dessinées réalistes comme
« Rahan », de Lécureux et Chéret.
Rahan, le fils des âges farouches,
ce garçon blond assez musclé,
qui traverse la préhistoire
avec son couteau d’ivoire.
Il y avait des BD humoristiques :
« Pif et Hercule », évidemment,
« Les Rigolus et les Tristus »
du génial Cézard,
et puis « La jungle en folie »
de Christian Godard et Mic Delinx.
Je me souviens avec nostalgie
de ces gags décalés, loufoques,
ou Joe Le Tigre, Mortimer,
le serpent « à sornettes »,
et Potame, le docteur spécialisé,
de son propre aveu, en n’importe quoi,
m’initiaient à leur façon à l’humour,
au non-sens, à la philosophie.
J'ai six ans, je me régale, je m'évade,
ça me parle, ça bouge, ça raconte.
Comment, au juste,
est-ce que ça raconte, la bande dessinée ?
Comment est-ce qu’à partir
d’images fixes peut jaillir un récit ?
Eh bien, la bande dessinée a
cette capacité entre les cases,
ces points de repère
qu’on nous offre pour suivre le récit.
Voici quelques images extraites
d’une bande dessinée assez fantastique -
« Mauvais genre » de Chloé Cruchaudet
aux éditions Delcourt.
Lorsque l’on passe
d’une vignette à l’autre,
le lecteur fabrique les mouvements
et les déplacements des personnages.
Nous devenons, sans en avoir
conscience, au plus profond de nous,
comme les animateurs d’un cinéma intime.
Nous fabriquons, à l’insu
de notre plein gré, en quelque sorte,
toutes les images interstitielles qui
nous permettent de compléter l’action
et de la comprendre.
C’est de cette façon
qu’on a accès au mouvement,
de notre capacité à donner la vie.
On peut avoir du mouvement à l’intérieur
d’une seule et même vignette.
Voyez plutôt.
Damien Cuvillier a réalisé cette case
à partir d’une case mythique de la BD.
Je pense que vous êtes un certain nombre
à avoir réussi à l’évoquer
dans vos propres cerveaux.
Elle vient évidemment
d’« Astérix et Cléopâtre »,
cinquième tome des aventures
d’un petit Gaulois moustachu,
chef-d’œuvre absolu
de René Goscinny et Albert Uderzo.
Simplement, Damien, ici, a remplacé
l’Égyptien amateur de potion magique
par Bécassine -
on verra plus tard pourquoi.
Si vous deviez décrire cette image,
vous diriez qu’elle représente Bécassine
venant de taper quelqu’un -
on ne sait pas qui -
tellement fort que ce personnage
est sorti de l’espace de la case.
Dans un coin, il y a un chien
qui a l’air touché
par ce qui est en train de se passer.
Il est rare, rarissime même,
qu’on se mette à décrire l’ensemble
des traits de mouvements qui s’y trouvent.
Cette zone avec les pointes,
qui fait la jonction
entre la trajectoire du bras
et la trajectoire de cet autre personnage
dont on ne sait toujours rien.
Ou qu’on décrive les gouttes de sueur
que l’on retrouve autour du chien.
C’est assez logique.
Ces éléments qui ne correspondent
à rien de figuratif,
tout ce qui ne représente pas Bécassine,
l’animal ou les chaussures,
ce sont des codes que ni vous
ni moi n’avons jamais appris,
ni à l’école, ni ailleurs,
et qui ont une particularité : ils
n’existent pas dans notre monde matériel.
Ils ne servent ici qu'à créer du
dynamisme et du mouvement.
Un peu de magie, faisons-les disparaître.
C'est autre chose.
On a Bécassine qui, dans ce mouvement,
est peut-être en train de réaliser
un exercice physique de musculation,
ou alors en train de protester -
une sorte de mouvement social
comme il en arrive parfois.
À côté, on a des chaussures qui flottent.
Peut-être est-ce qu’elles protestent
aussi contre la notion même de gravité.
Et on a ce chien
qui pourrait être une statue
du genre dont on orne nos jardins.
L'image, une fois nue, a été privée
de son dynamisme, de son énergie.
Elle est statique,
Ne souffrons pas plus longtemps,
retrouvons notre image d’origine.
Et là, je comprends tout.
Tout à coup, c’est vous,
c’est vous, lecteurs de cette image,
qui aviez transformé des codes
et en aviez fait le mouvement.
Vous aviez converti tout ça en action.
Ça y est, on l’a compris, la BD, ça bouge.
C’est établi, dans notre imaginaire,
certes, mais ça bouge.
Mais au-delà du « Vlôn » qui est ici,
est-ce que ça fait du bruit,
la bande dessinée ?
Est-ce qu’à partir d’images fixes,
on peut créer du son ?
La réponse est peut-être apportée par des
découvertes récentes des neurosciences,
basées sur des progrès de l’imagerie
médicale et de l’imagerie cérébrale.
Elles démontrent que lorsque
nous lisons de façon silencieuse,
nous stimulons une zone
particulière de notre cerveau
qui est habituellement dédiée
à la réception du langage oral.
Autrement dit,
lorsque nous lisons de cette façon,
nous produisons probablement
dans une zone de notre cerveau
une bande son interne -
ça, on s’en doute un peu -
mais il y a une autre zone de ce cerveau
qui est là pour recevoir ce message,
pour écouter et entendre
ce que nous ne disons pas.
Il y a une anecdote assez fabuleuse
dans l’histoire de la BD,
qui est liée à la sortie en 1964
d’un film avec acteurs,
« Tintin et les Oranges Bleues ».
Vous l’avez peut-être vu ici.
Un jeune spectateur écrivit à Hergé pour
dire qu’il avait trouvé le film formidable
sauf le capitaine Haddock qui n’avait
pas la même voix que dans les albums.
(Rires)
Ça ne s'invente pas.
On peut rappeler que l’invention
de l’écriture avait un objectif initial
qui était de reproduire l'expression orale
C'est étrange, mais c'est ainsi.
La lecture silencieuse est arrivée
plus tard dans l’histoire.
Il faut attendre le 5ᵉ siècle
de notre ère,
sous la plume d’un certain saint Augustin,
pour en avoir une trace écrite.
Il vient de vivre
une scène qui l’a bouleversé.
Il ne savait pas que c’était possible :
il a vu un moine, ce moine lisait,
aucun son ne sortait de sa bouche.
Si on y pense,
lorsqu’un enfant apprend la lecture,
il enchaîne des syllabes à voix haute.
C’est plus tard
qu’il se met à lire à voix basse
et puis finalement à lire,
quelque, part de l’intérieur.
Si la bande dessinée n’a pas la capacité
à produire des bandes sons
comparables à celle du cinéma,
elle dispose quand même
d’outils graphiques surpuissants -
on en voit ici quelques-uns -
mais surtout d’un allié surpuissant :
notre cerveau, votre cerveau.
La bande dessinée nous guide en nous
donnant des informations diverses.
Elle peut nous transmettre des dialogues,
des pavés de textes,
des sons par le biais des onomatopées.
C'est le cas ici.
Elle peut nous donner des indications
sur l’émotion, sur le volume,
par l’épaisseur, la taille,
la forme, des caractères.
Toutes les inventions sont possibles
et imaginables, parce qu’en BD,
les textes sont des images.
Même les lettres sont dessinées
dans les bulles.
C’est tous ces moyens qu’a appelés ici
à son service Midam
dans cette formidable série,
« Kid paddle », aux éditions Dupuis.
Mais Midam, quand il fait cela, ne fait
pas que jouer avec le dessin du son.
Il nous entraîne de case en case
par un enchaînement subtil à la
compréhension d’une histoire, d’un gag.
Comment est-ce que la BD
produit du récit cette fois-ci ?
Comment est-ce qu’à partir d’images
fixes on peut obtenir ce récit ?
Là encore, on va réfléchir
à la mécanique à l’œuvre
dans nos cerveaux, dans vos cerveaux.
Je vous propose un exercice, une petite
expérience collective paranormale.
Vous avez eu le temps de découvrir
ces images, de les décrypter,
de les lire, de leur donner un sens
Si je disposais de pouvoirs paranormaux,
de la capacité à rentrer
dans vos cerveaux -
je ne dis pas que je peux le faire -
si je disposais de ces pouvoirs
et que j’avais la faculté
d’aller assister aux scènes
que vous avez reconstituées,
j’aurais probablement accès
à autant de moments dramatiques
qu’il y a de gens ici.
J’imagine que d’une façon ou d’une autre,
vous avez l’impression
d’avoir assisté à un crime.
Eh bien, ce n’est pas si simple que ça.
Hormis le fait que ces images
sont réalisées en noir et blanc,
elles sont fort différentes.
Celle de gauche
est dessiné d’un trait fin, régulier,
agrémenté de quelques zones hachurées.
La suivante propose des aplats noirs
puis des zones aussi,
mais des zones matiérées, texturées,
larges, probablement réalisées
au pinceau ou à la brosse.
Peut-être que ces deux images
n’ont rien à voir l’une avec l’autre.
Peut être produites
par deux artistes différents.
Peut-être que la première témoigne
d’un moment tout à fait banal
chez un adolescent amateur de films
et qui tapisse sa chambre
d’affiches de films d’horreur.
et que la seconde correspond au moment
précis où, de l’autre côté de la planète,
une personne retrouve enfin
le ticket gagnant de loterie
qu’elle croyait avoir perdu à jamais.
Quoi qu'il en soit, on voit ici à l'œuvre
un des moteurs de la bande dessinée.
Nous avons une fâcheuse tendance,
nous humains,
à chercher du sens à ce qui nous entoure.
Il suffit qu’on oppose côte à côte
deux images
et nous leur cherchons,
et leur trouvons, un sens commun
en les liant grâce aux indices,
aux signes qui s’y trouvent.
Pour lire un album complet, un classique,
un tome des Schtroumpfs de Peyo,
on nous demande de faire cette gymnastique
près de 800 fois dans un album,
de passer la case, d’aller d’une case
à l’autre, de franchir la passerelle,
de remplir le blanc entre les images,
de résoudre l’ellipse.
Et pour ce faire, nous mobilisons
notre imaginaire, toutes nos lectures,
nos expériences de vie, les films,
les séries que nous avons pu regarder.
Auparavant, on a parlé du mouvement,
du son, mais c’est le récit lui-même
que nous finalisons,
que vous avez finalisé.
Ce crime, d’une certaine façon,
c’est vous qui l’avez commis.
Je n'accuse personne.
Mais enfin, quand même...
Comme le dit très justement un auteur
américain qui s’appelle Scott McLeod
dans un livre assez incroyable
qui s’appelle « L’art invisible » :
« Dans les limbes du cerveau,
l’imagination humaine se saisit
de deux images distinctes
pour les transformer en unité unique. »
Je vous laisserai aussi méditer là-dessus.
Ces voix de la bande dessinée
qui m’ont saisi à l’âge de six ans,
elles ne m’ont pas lâché depuis.
J’ai lu, beaucoup, peut-être trop.
J’ai dévoré, j’ai cherché à comprendre -
tout comprendre,
l’histoire du médium, ses techniques,
ses codes, ses courants.
J’ai cherché aussi à identifier
ce qui m’attirait dans le neuvième art,
ce qui me fascinait, ce qui me touchait.
J’ai été à la rencontre des artistes
à Saint-Malo, Bruxelles,
Angoulême ou ailleurs.
Mais c’est ici, pour partager
cette passion dévorante
qu’avec huit complices,
j’ai créé un festival.
Amiens, d’une certaine façon,
un peu souterraine,
avait déjà un rapport privilégié
à la bande dessinée.
Amiens, c’est la ville de naissance
de Joseph Porphyre Pinchon.
Il y en a qui savent, mais est-ce
que tout le monde savait ça ?
Joseph Porphyre Pinchon,
c’est le créateur de Bécassine en 1905.
Son style graphique a
une influence énorme, énorme,
sur toute une génération d’artistes
dont un jeune dessinateur, Georges Remi,
qui allait prendre le pseudonyme d’Hergé,
puis créer Tintin en 1929.
Ce n'est pas rien.
Amiens, c'est aussi la ville de naissance
de Jean-Christophe Menu.
Auteur, éditeur, il a cofondé
la maison d’édition « L’Association »
et il l’a animée
pendant de nombreuses années.
À partir de 1990, cette structure
a développé les divergences qui manquaient
dans la bande dessinée
et dans son paysage.
On y a découvert qu’on pouvait traiter
dans le neuvième art l’autobiographie,
le social, le politique, l’intime.
L’autobiographie, avec l’exemple frappant
du Persépolis de Marjane Satrapi.
On y a découvert qu’il y aurait
un large lectorat pour cela.
Alors le temps a passé, encore.
Amiens est aujourd’hui un territoire où,
chaque année, en juin, se tient
un événement majeur du neuvième art :
les rendez-vous de la BD d’Amiens.
Ils ont accueilli depuis tout ce temps
plus de 1200 autrices et auteurs,
avec des expositions et des affiches
d’artistes aussi incroyables,
majeurs et divers,
que Enki Bilal, Jean Roba qui écrivait
et dessinait Boule et Bill,
l’immense mangaka Jirō Taniguchi,
François Schuiten,
pour lequel on a exposé son travail,
aussi bien des Cités obscures
que son récent « Blake et Mortimer »,
Paul Gillon, cher à mon cœur,
et cette année, Chloé Cruchaudet,
dont vous avez déjà vu quelques images.
Au cœur d’une société où la photo
et la vidéo sont omniprésentes,
où la communication s’appuie sans cesse
sur des images qu’elle déverse
sur nos terminaux numériques,
au cœur de nos villes,
jusque dans nos poches,
la bande dessinée nous invite
à reprendre le contrôle,
à recevoir ses images
et ses pages, certes,
mais à les vivre et à les lire
à notre propre rythme.
Pfouf ! Ralentissons !
Jubilons dans un grand décor -
imaginez-le -
qui fourmille de détails.
Ou tournons vite la page
pour suivre une action palpitante.
Revenons en arrière de quelques pages -
c’est un luxe -
et devenons le temps d’un album
metteur en scène,
directeur d’acteurs, bruiteur, animateur.
Redevenons surtout, un instant,
ces enfants qui dessinaient
et lisaient le monde,
avant.
(Applaudissements)